welcome to this video playing dr. John
none yeah he probably knows some stuff
about the Trump Ian the Trump being a
principal weapon of so many English
players hmm maybe not such a good choice
ok c 3 I think d 5 yeah it's the more
aggressive things I really don't know
that well there's this line any good and
the detail I mean this is what I'm
trying to say it but failing and he's
got queen of five now this is one idea
or this one yeah but this is not isn't
this okay for me I can take with the
porn here right I'm totally forgetting
how would this is played a five
interesting hmm now is maybe trying to
weaken the dark squares yeah very very
quickly like a4a 492 a three it's very
well at this point
yes still many for looks totally normal
I mean so nice to wear to d2 I guess he
really insists on doing that very
interesting so we'll be three is really
weakening a lot so maybe I have to take
it ok trying to take with the bishop so
I just try to develop him 492 my bishop
on f4 is kind of a misplaced here in the
situation of it k looks a lot now like a
friendship where he has gotten this
early early queenside queenside play
yeah i wonder if there's any way to not
close the position so quickly can I do
this maybe yeah I have no idea I mean
the bishop belongs there any way for the
e5 structure oh I forgot about this move
oh that's embarrassing those two two
bishops now Oh horrible ok we should be
three was ridiculous am really was okay
I'm down two minutes and I have a crappy
position now unbelievable stuff oh wow
check and still check I am totally in
the ropes here the bishop is hanging up
on e3 end there's also 93 in the in the
mix colombi three just try to hold hold
on here total opening disaster I
recapture what is he doing Quincy six
probably but anyway what what else
Quincy 6 492 yeah all that one which is
this so brilliant I mean I can go here
I'd
gap this looks terrible well maybe you
look see one look see 195 oh these kind
of ideas yeah I can you can take there
but not sure how good it is I can take
and maybe play g6 or something like that
or this movie are still 95 Bishop g5
that's not good so I have to move the
king which runs into 93 hmm okay Wow
what an opening disaster real real
disaster night night somewhere we'd be
too I runs into checks on d3 as well I
am time warning
I'd be five Teague thoughts are not not
possible might be five quinta check on
CH I don't know it's lost anyway so
let's just do something in check hoping
for I don't know what actually it says
really totally lost now I can play any
move here actually in the rook hangs but
it just goes awesome well check let's
check on d3 a.m. oh wow okay white
resign yeah this happens if you play an
opening that you don't know really and
if the opponent knows something okay so
this this 9283 takes went here i have to
improve around here the big issue was
that i really i thought that when you
and II 6 that you always would take with
the bishop and of course he does not
have to do that yeah this is just the
total M&A after Luke a 3m I'm in big
trouble already I mean simply have no
move here so no good move computer wants
to do this but this is terrible m this
is a terrible position no this is just
full of full of holes now can can give
this check and this is this is just
crappy I'm really bad for what so that i
played this which is even worse check
check
it's it's just it's just unplayable
really yeah I'm just lost in there is no
no way to save that with the King
running around and stuff like that I
really didn't didn't think about Rupa
takes a three so uh what exactly does
this mean so a five really is in day 366
is there some thermals what be three
looks wrong yeah this looks wrong giving
away the the before square and things
like that I think taking is probably
okay it's funny at a computer the the
stock fish air it wants to take here and
then play Bishop to b5 funny maybe that
is really interesting I mean if it takes
now Queen a4 is really really really
problematic em like this and black is
lost it can happen really easily now
computer wants to do something like that
but this this is now upon yeah what is
upon up well it's not the greatest
whatever but I mean I don't have the the
dark squared bishop anymore it weakens
the dark squares but also means that i
will probably don't have a structurally
bad minor piece yeah this is what i
should do here it seems it seems okay I
really the thing is I absolutely it was
just like I absolutely did not see that
that here um yeah that you can take with
the rook it's just so so bad yeah okay
well thanks for watching